what about all the trash talk how much
of that did you learn does that come
naturally to you you're you're one of
the most charismatic fun i mean there's
always like respect behind it i would
say to me
and i'm a fan of a lot of sports you're
one of the greatest trash talkers in all
of sports that i've ever seen because
you're able to talk
but there's so much love and respect
behind it it's just masterful but you
also get into people's heads yeah in the
moment it's beautiful to watch because
they it really gets
it gets to some people so where does
that come from this powerful weapon
right yeah it's your voice is a powerful
powerful weapon
and it's under utilized by so many
athletes because they think that it's
not sportsmanlike or
something like that but the truth is i
mean
you can be a a weak
person
but with your voice you can influence
and change any number of things
and the same thing happens in a in a
fight between two people
if you can just be a never-ending you
know
flow of negative encouragement to
someone or you know
you know suggestion
uh anything can happen
it's a tool um
and when you're fighting a person you're
not just fighting them
you're fighting everyone who's watching
you're fighting
the crowd the referees
and
you know to get in the most ideal
positions situations you need to use
your voice
yeah yeah and there's uh
for people who haven't seen i i
definitely recommend you watch a bunch
of arm wrestling matches because um
there's a crowd really gets into it and
it feels
it feels like there's a really intimate
connection with the crowd i suppose
because the crowd is allowed to be very
close to you yeah and says i love it
i i want the crowd like right up on me
yeah yeah
so sometimes
oh yeah
who are whenever you talk to somebody
you literally pick somebody from the
crowd yes oh yeah i'll i'll i'll
him like i'll start off his fans
and like
yeah like i'll start talking to their
wives or whatever yeah
yeah uh yeah there's jody um
she's pretty dangerous to to listen to
also but yeah one of his buddies mike
solaris who's you know
really good arm wrestler was was talking
was cheering for him so i started go
after him yeah yeah
smiling the whole time yeah it's fun
right it's fun it's yeah fan is fun to
listen to but it's also what's fun is
how much it actually affects some of the
people you're facing they get frustrated
yeah it's great to see well you have to
fight right
like a lot of people think things will
be given to them and and the thing that
you know i've always believed from the
time i was very young like uh
i i i was convinced that uh
our inevitable death was gonna come from
aliens right
like some super aggressive
super violent species was gonna come and
smoke us all
you know and i'm like
i'm i'm not like that i'm like but as
soon as one person is
then you're forced to have to accept it
as reality right
so
i like to fight
for
every single thing i like to try and be
more and more aggressive and if someone
matches me
that's when i can use my endurance and
if they don't then i have the tactical
advantage
so that's kind of my my balance point
and then by the way you also yell at the
ref yeah i mean the games there's like
levels to this game but you know
the feeling sometimes when people get
frustrated it's like okay this person's
cheating or like
you're trying to get a good grip
uh
before the go before it goes
and and and i think some of the
frustration in combination with the
trash talk is what this person is
cheating right but everybody is like
kind of trying to cheat get an edge
within the rules yeah
so i try and just ramp it ramp it ramp
it
but uh you know everybody's different
i've learned how to play the game
based off of the tools that i have
physically yeah and for me
this works because you know my genetic
makeup
is more i'm more of a persistence hunter
right so like i need to extend things
and
that works well for me
um
you know if i was ex more explosive
i probably wouldn't have the same
strategies
you